intense rainfall winds of 120 km/h or
higher
storm surge these are the signs of a
hurricane
during its reign of terror a hurricane
can release as much energy as 10,000
nuclear bombs and guess what there are
two of them and they're on a collision
course this is what if and here's what
would happen if two hurricanes collided
meet dr. Saku hi food awara
the Japanese meteorologists who first
defined the interaction between two
hurricanes the Fujiwara effect describes
what happens when two whirling weather
systems called cyclonic vortexes come
close to each other
cyclonic vortexes could be hurricanes or
typhoons and if they get within 1,000
kilometers of each other they can be
even more dangerous it doesn't occur
very often but it does happen and some
scientists believe that it will happen
more often as global temperatures
continue to rise
the term hurricane gets its name from
Horicon known in Mayan mythology as a
god of wind storm and fire and you're
about to see why hurricanes and typhoons
form when warm moist air over the ocean
rises and nearby air takes its place
forming swirls of air as the warm rising
air cools it makes huge clouds filled
with moisture these clouds continue to
spin and expand causing intense rain
wind and surging tides wherever the
storm goes hurricanes can be extremely
costly both in material damages and in
human lives so how much more devastation
can we expect when two hurricanes
collide
you might be looking up at two
approaching storms and think to yourself
that can't be good
and you'd be right but how bad things
are about to become for you really
depends on how big the storm is if two
hurricanes are about the same size and
strength they'll do the dance and orbit
around a common center the result of
this dance might send both storms off in
different directions they could be
catastrophic for any city or region that
wasn't prepared for a hurricane but if
one of the hurricanes is bigger than the
other the larger one can absorb the
smaller one this wouldn't create some
kind of mega storm like you see in the
movies with astronomical wind speeds and
storm surges that wipe out whole cities
but two hurricanes combined could still
make the hurricane stronger and
longer-lasting hurricanes are the most
deadly storms so increasing their
strength can have a massive impact on
people's lives on the economy and on
health care systems whenever they hit
populated areas Hurricane Katrina was
the costliest hurricane to hit the
United States so far and that was only a
category three storm a climatologist at
the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology Kerry Emanuel believes that
wind speeds in a hurricane could
increase by about five percent for every
one degree increase in tropical ocean
temperatures a category five storm has
winds of 252 km/h or stronger will we
one day have to classify a category six
storm
let's hope not but there are other
reasons why we should try to keep the
earth's temperature from rising do you
know what would happen if all the
world's ice melted well that's a story
for another what if
[Music]